- Good afternoon everyone.
I am Saad Omer
and the Director of the Yale
Institute for Global Health.
And I'm delighted to welcome you
to the YGH Global Health
conversation series.
Our latest event in this series.
We, in addition to YGH we are indebted
to the George Herbert
Walker Jr. Lecture series
that is supported by the Macmillan center.
Today, I'm pleased to be
joined by my co-moderator
Dr. Linda Arnold.
She's an Associate Professor of Pediatrics
and Emergency Medicine at
Yale School of Medicine.
She's a former Peace Corps volunteer
and she has been actively engaged
in global health and education.
In fact, I, you know,
the first time I met her,
we were both in Panama and her effort,
and she was doing work
on capacity building.
And in addition to that,
she has worked on program development
for more than 30 years.
She's also the North
American representative
to the standing committee
of the International
Pediatric Association.
Welcome Linda, it's great
to have you with us today.
And as a reminder
all attendees have their
volumes and video features muted
but of course, we are eager
to incorporate your questions.
You can simply submit those questions
using the question and answer feature.
We are also recording today's session
and it will be available
on YouTube and the YGH Facebook page.
And now let me introduced everyone,
to today's distinguished
guest Henrietta Fore.
Who's the seventh executive
director of UNICEF,
which, a position she
began in January, 2018.
She is not new to global
health and development.
And she's been a real champion
of economic development
education, health, and
humanitarian assistance
as well as disaster relief
in a public service,
as well as a private sector
a non profit leadership career
that spans more than four decades.
One of her career highlights
is that she was the,
between 2007 and 2009,
she was the executive director,
well she was the
administrator of the USAID.
And she was the first woman to serve
in this role and was responsible for
managing approximately $40 billion
of US foreign assistance annually.
Including support to peoples and countries
recovering from disasters,
building their futures
economically, politically and socially
Before her career at USAID,
she was appointed assistant
administrator for Asia
and assistant administrator
for private enterprise
in the same agency.
She serves on the boards of
Overseas Private Investment Corporation
and the Millennium Challenge Corporation.
And in, 2009 Executive Director Fore
received the distinguished service award
the highest award the
secretary of state can bestow.
So without further ado
you know, I wanna welcome
Executive Director Fore
and, you know, look
forward to talking about
some of the issues that
we'll be focusing on.
In terms of the way it will go.
We would appreciate,
we'll start with Director
Fore's remarks, brief remarks
and then we'll have a
question answer session,
which Dr. Arnold and I will moderate.
And we'll also take audience questions.
- Well, thank you very much.
Saad, I really appreciate
it and I will start formally
and then let's get into
a good conversation.
So thank you very much.
And also thank you very much
to the Yale Institute for Global Health
for welcoming me here today.
We have a number of programs
that we do together,
which are all exciting
and they lead to, in
many paths of the future.
So they lead to many areas
that we're going to be talking about.
And so I appreciate it.
We appreciate it at UNICEF very much.
I am looking forward to
discussing with all of you,
what is truly an emergency of our time,
and it is, COVID-19.
What we need to do as a global community
to support children's health and wellbeing
through and importantly,
beyond this extraordinary time.
And I say a global
community very deliberately,
building and strengthening
systems for the future
cannot be done alone
by governments or agencies like UNICEF.
It requires the ideas and the innovations
the funding, the collaboration
of an ecosystem of partners,
all working together.
Collaboration has
certainly been a hallmark
of the Yale UNICEF partnership
across collaborative ties
between us are strong and
also they are growing.
UNICEF has benefited
from Yale's leadership
in global health fellowship
with two Yale students
who've been working in our
health section this past summer
Nicholas Alipui, Yale's lecturer
at the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs
was a long time senior leader at UNICEF.
And he is now bringing his expertise
to the Capstone course on
non-communicable diseases at Yale.
And every year, UNICEF
welcomes Yale's experts
in a diverse number of areas.
From child nutrition and feeding
to early childhood development to HIV AIDS
and of critical importance today
the vaccine demand laboratory,
which Saad is leading
with one of UNICEF,
senior social scientists.
But I hope that we can continue
to do even more together
in the years ahead.
In fact, the diversity of
thinking around the many areas
of children's health and wellbeing
is part of what I would like
to leave with you today.
We cannot support children's health
if we fail to support all
of the other ingredients
that support their
development and wellbeing.
Education, protection
from violence and abuse,
water and sanitation, mental health,
nutrition, social protections,
skills development,
so they can prepare for the world of work.
All of these ingredients help support
optimal health and development.
And all of the systems that
support these ingredients
came under attack with COVID-19.
The unprecedented measures
that we have taken
to contain the virus.
Schools were closed leaving
1.6 billion children
out of school,
immunization campaigns around
the world ground to a halt,
parents stopped taking their
children to medical centers
because they were afraid
of coming into contact with the virus.
Households were hit hard
by the economic impact.
Families are finding it
difficult to make ends meet
for even the most important
and basic necessities like food
and children and women have
become more exposed to violence
and abuse online, but also
within their own households.
But what about those places
where these systems were already
weak or even non-existent?
Places where primary health
care is a day's journey
or more from where people live,
or crowded conditions make it
impossible to self distance
where a family of seven or
even 10 share a single room,
where humanitarian emergencies
like conflicts make reaching children
with basic services like
vaccinations or treatment
for severe acute malnutrition
extraordinarily difficult.
Where one of the best
defenses against COVID-19,
hand-washing, is simply out of reach
because of lack of clean
water and a bar of soap.
COVID-19 has reminded us all
of the stark inequalities around the world
between the haves and the have-nots
and in the most extreme cases
places of conflict or
drought, for example, in Yemen
or in the Sahil,
or for refugees living
in overcrowded camps.
And the pandemic is making
that situation even worse.
In many ways, UNICEF was made
for this kind of an emergency
with offices in over 190 countries
our staff members are
working shoulder to shoulder
with governments to deliver nutrition,
to vaccinate children, provide water,
emergency healthcare, education
and protection services
to the displaced.
Our staff members and
partners, are also working
to give development a foothold
in parts of the world where
a vaccination, a bed net
a drink of clean water,
a cup of nutritious food
a seat at a classroom or a paved road
can seem like a distant dream.
And we're directly supporting
the COVID-19 response
on a number of fronts.
We're delivering life saving supplies.
We're working with communities
to provide information and
messaging to prevent infection.
We're providing online
and distance learning
to millions of out of school children.
We're keeping vaccination
campaigns up and running.
We're providing water,
sanitation and hygiene supplies
to communities that are battling COVID-19.
We're playing the lead role
in the ACT Accelerator
initiative at the COVAX facility
to ensure that any vaccine is delivered
fairly and inequitably around the world.
And throughout we're working
shoulder to shoulder with governments
as they rebuild stronger
schools, hospitals,
resilient water and sanitation
services for the future.
And we're helping them to strengthen
lasting community-based health systems
where all of the services
that children and their families need
from vaccinations, to
nutrition, to obstetric care
can be found in one place
because supporting children's
health and wellbeing
depends on supporting the whole child,
their health, but also their development
their education, and
their access to services.
Today, I look forward to
discussing how UNICEF is working
with our partners around the world
public and private alike
to meet these needs
and to use this moment as a chance
to re-imagine the systems
that children are counting on.
But we'd also like to hear from you.
I'm sure that many of
you will answer the call
to public and global service
in the health field and beyond.
Perhaps you'll go to work in
agencies and organizations
dedicated to the education
and economic empowerment
of young people
or become development professionals
diplomats, policy professionals, NGO,
or civil society workers, innovators,
business people, and teachers.
So please let us know your thoughts,
contribute any research
or ideas you might have
on solutions or technologies
that might better serve
children and young people.
Consider doing a report
on the issues affecting
their lives and futures
and send us your ideas on innovations.
We need you on this journey with us,
through your work you can make
a difference in the world.
You can build brighter futures
for a generation of children.
So once again, thank you very much
and back to you, Saad and Linda.
- Thanks, so I'll start
with the questions.
The, obviously there has
been a lot of disruption
of routine services, as you mentioned
and including immunization services
and UNICEF along with
it's in-country partners
often forms the backbone
of the technical capacity
that various countries have.
What is your assessment
of the current situation?
Has, do you think there
has been a bounce-back
in immunization services?
Do you think,
I know that you issued a call
for resumption of these services lately,
so if in terms of your expectations
whether the system is
likely to bounce back soon?
- So the honest answer
is we don't know yet.
What has happened is
that primary healthcare services are down.
So routine immunizations,
those routine immunizations that you get
when you are less than one year old
or less than five years old are way down.
In some of our countries,
they are down 40 to 60%.
And some of that is due to
supplies being interrupted.
It has been difficult to find
air freight, cargo space,
it has been difficult
sometimes to cross the airspace
sometimes to cross into the country,
to allow for delivery.
At other times
it is because a family is worried
that if they go to a
primary health clinic,
that they will get COVID-19
or another disease,
and they are just worried.
So routine immunizations are down.
And as you know, they
have to be in a pattern
and we are very worried that
families are not coming back
in the same numbers that
they should be coming back.
And we're worried about measles.
We're worried about polio.
Then we also have campaigns
and campaigns really, such
as the polio campaign,
they become a big push and it
is backed by the government.
They want to make sure that they vaccinate
a hundred percent of the children
or as close as we can get to it.
And we go by field area within a country.
These campaigns are more likely
to be coming back quickly
and Saad, I can tell you
that they are coming back.
So the specialty campaigns
are starting to come back
into the system again.
But we have one other real problem
which is that there is
a lot on social media
that are negative commentaries
about getting a vaccination,
that if you do vaccinate
that your children will get
whatever that disease is
that you're being vaccinated from.
We have got to be able to
counter the misinformation
that is often too ubiquitous
on the internet and in
social media platforms
that say that you should worry
that you should have vaccine hesitancy.
We need to be able to convince
people that vaccines work.
They do work.
We know they work, but we
need families to believe it.
And to come in and to get
their children vaccinated.
It's also gonna be true
for adults in COVID-19.
So Saad, any ideas that
you and the school have
on ways that we can talk
about getting vaccinations,
this would be very important.
- Yeah, well, thank you.
And in fact, as you alluded to,
we are starting and have
started a partnership
with UNICEF on specifically
on addressing misinformation
and in certain cases,
unfortunately disinformation,
but using evidence-based
approaches to do so
because, you know, just like we need
to bring the best science
to vaccine development,
we need to bring the best set of evidence
from social sciences and
other quantitative sciences
and other sciences
to addressing misinformation
and disinformation.
I'll give the next question to Linda.
- Many of us are concerned that
during the pandemic, there
has been a disparate effect
of COVID related restrictions and systems
and services disruptions
on children who are living in poverty
and members of other at-risk
or marginalized populations.
And we've all heard reports
of increased food insecurity,
domestic violence,
sexual abuse, child,
marriage, and child labor.
What kinds of things are
you seeing in the field?
- Well, I wish I could tell
you that we were not seeing
any of those things, but we are,
we're seeing all of them.
So one of the things that happens
in COVID-19 is that resources
and services are rearranged.
(muffled speaking)
And what it means is that some
of your healthcare workers
who had been working on another area
are now redirected to working on COVID.
So part of what we are very worried about
are the noncommunicable diseases.
And you mentioned things
like child marriage
and you mentioned some areas
that we often don't speak about,
which is the mental health problems
and these all need counseling
and they need psychosocial support
so that when our workforces
out around the world are
diverted into something else
because these are usually
very thin capacities
but when they are now battling COVID-19
then the support in other areas drops off.
So the needs are great.
It is true in almost every country.
We worry the most to your very good point
about the poorest countries.
We worry about the poorest populations
in the poorest countries.
And we particularly
worried about the girls.
So girls become liable
for early child marriage.
It is often because their
parents wish to keep them safe.
And they believe that
when they reach puberty
that to keep them safe means
that they should marry them.
They do not have the economic
wherewithal to keep them,
and that they worry that going to school
will not be helpful.
So child marriage looms very large
for girls on many continents.
We also worry about just household work.
Girls being kept out of secondary school.
You know, the numbers,
primary school almost all
children have a chance
to go to primary school
but then the numbers drop
way off for secondary school.
And for girls that usually is,
staying in the household, look
after older family members
or child marriage.
For boys, it is usually
that they are getting lured
into some form of a service to a militia,
or that they are asked to make
a living out on the streets
to earn money for their family.
And with the economic crisis
that has come with COVID-19,
if your father or mother are without work,
you go out to work
as a young man or as a young woman.
And we are very worried
that they will never return to school.
And that's what we saw
during the Ebola crisis
is that at least half of the
girls did not return to school.
So it's important.
We need to be thinking about the children
that are most vulnerable
and we need to think
about the reallocation
of resources within a country
so that you can invest in
children and young people.
- I know that you talked
a bit earlier about
challenges and difficulties in getting
food and nutrition to children
in sort of far off places,
or really anywhere during the pandemic.
Have there been strategies that
have been successful kind of?
- So one of the things we dream about
is to really look at systems.
So food systems operate
from a rural farm to an urban center,
and you know the numbers,
urbanization is moving
along at a very fast pace.
And what it means is the diets change.
There's a different diet
when you are living on your own farm,
than there is when you
go into an urban center.
But food systems need
to follow the population
and they need to provide a diverse diet.
We believe that at least
one out of every three children
are not getting the
nutrition that they need.
Two are not,
two out of three are not
getting a diverse diet.
So what does that mean?
Either that it's not affordable
or that it's not accessible
or that their parents or they do not know
what would comprise a nutritious diet.
but it has long lasting effects,
so if a child is not properly nourished
in that first three years of life
that first thousand days,
it just means that their
bones do not grow as strong
that their brains do not
grow as well connected
as children, who've had a
better chance at nutrition.
And if we are to ever
catch stunting or wasting
and stop them in their tracks
we are going to have to get
these food systems to work.
So food systems are extremely important.
And then there's one other,
very sobering statistic.
Young people don't want
to be farmers anymore.
They see their parents just
struggling to make it on a farm
and they leave the farms,
they go to the cities
where there's digital connectivity
they're adolescents, and it's very hard.
So we're going to need lots of farmers.
They're gonna have to
be digitally connected.
But young people are gonna
have to want to be farmers
or the food systems cannot work well.
And during COVID-19, we've
seen many border closures.
So food systems were stopped often
but we need governments to help us.
We need businesses to help us.
We need schools to help us to train
but we need above all good food systems.
And the realization that
nutrition is important
not just for small children
but also for adolescent mothers
for everyone in every stage of life.
- Great, so there is, you know
in this outbreak,
it has been an all hands on deck situation
and where everyone has to come together
at the country level
and at the global level.
And UNICEF has provided
some of the most useful
pair of hands in this global effort.
But the reality is
that this outbreak is not
just impacting children
it's impacting adults
particularly, but not
exclusively the elderly.
And UNICEF's stated mission
focuses on children.
And so how do you sort of resolve that
not tension, you know,
that alignment or how do
you deal with that alignment
in terms of UNICEF's child focused mission
but having skills and
resources and capacity
specifically at the country level
that is so useful and essential
for a pandemic response
that goes beyond children?
- Well, so Saad, we try to
be available for everyone
in our expertise and our knowledge
and our country presence
which is indeed a real asset
at this moment in time.
So what happens when COVID-19 hits?
The government often talks
about what they should be doing
with their budgets and
what should they invest in.
And we try to make the case
and I hope we're making it well,
that an investment in children
is the best investment you can make.
They are the ultimate investment,
as they often say
we're 25% of the world, but
we're 100% of your future.
So we try to convince governments
that they need to make an investment
in education and health systems
primarily, but for children.
The second is
that the expertise that we carry often
follows in a child's life.
So for instance
mental health is something
that we have not talked
about in our age group,
because we were afraid to do so.
You didn't tell your family,
you certainly didn't
tell your boss at work,
or you might lose your job,
but this generation of young people,
they want to talk about it.
We have to make it okay.
So what UNICEF can do in a country
is talk about mental health
and how important it is.
In most mental health problems
start by the age of 14.
So if we do not catch
it early, in childhood,
it means that there will be repercussions
in the decades to come
in the adult population.
And the lockdown and the
restrictions in movement
have created a lot of violence,
physical and sexual at home.
It has also created a new
dynamic in many households
because one or another of the breadwinners
has lost their economic income.
It creates tension and violence
in a way that we have not seen.
So helplines, parenting forums
are all extremely important.
So you might think
that that was just because
you UNICEF knew children
but it's because children
live in families.
And we look after the families.
And for UNICEF it will be important
to look after mental health,
to keep families together.
It will be important to look
after water and water system
to try to keep communities
safe and clean, hygienic.
It will be important to
look after distance learning
because children need to be in school.
It's their futures.
And we've got to focus on immunization
because children can lose their lives
to measles or another
disease rather than to COVID.
And then to Linda's earlier point
we must be able to make sure
that there's enough nutrition and food.
So the children can move
beyond this COVID time
and they still have
healthy, strong bodies.
- I, thank you for even alluding to
just the numerous needs that children have
and how those early and
foundational childhood experiences
and health status can sort
of have lifelong effects.
One of the things that we as
pediatricians always stress
is the importance of play
towards normal development.
And at a time when everyone
is incredibly stressed out
when you know, there's
a lot of tension around
children are out of school,
taking on other roles,
what can be done at the
country level and globally
to promote the importance of
just regular childhood play
and routine physical activity
in terms of children's wellbeing
and normal childhood development.
- Thank you Linda.
Well we do believe in play
and I hope you're going to allow
some of these students that are still
around the Yale center time to play also
because we never grow out of it.
But during the height of the pandemic,
when there were many lockdown restrictions
that you must stay in your apartments,
and this is in many of the
highly developed cities
in Europe or in North America,
it was very hard on children
because they want to go play
and you can't necessarily play
in the apartment that you're living in.
And there, all of a sudden,
the apartments seem very small
and very crowded, and you
didn't have any friends there.
And so it's very hard on a child.
So we were encouraging
that there'd be times every day
when children could go out and play
and they could go out and
play just right around
their apartment building
or that there might be a nearby park
that they could go to safely
at a distance and they could go play.
But it's very important,
it's part of the makeup
of a childhood and of
a healthy young adult.
So it's a very important issue.
We've been speaking up about it,
but we can use the help
of every pediatrician
who can prescribe it to families
and to governments alike.
- Very nice, so we have a question
from our students compiled
by one of our faculty members
who teachers our global health course.
And so a number of our
public health students
and others are passionate
about working in humanitarian sector.
What are the skills,
especially skills of the future
that you think they should acquire
for them to be able to
serve more effectively
in the humanitarian sector?
Both in health and otherwise as well.
- So be a problem solver
I don't think we can teach
you everything in school,
and we can't teach you
everything with books,
but you will learn from
the context you're in
the beauty of the world around us
is that we have thousands
upon thousands of cultures
and they will all react differently.
So there'll be different ways
that you can affect them.
And when you get out into the field
with an agency like UNICEF,
you will see the environment
and the ecosystem that we are working in
building trust with your community
is one of the most important things
that anyone working in
health can do or education,
but in health particularly.
We saw it in the Democratic
Republic of Congo,
when Ebola first came in,
if a community health worker
spoke the local dialects
and was of the community
and was considered an important
member of a community,
they were listened to,
people paid attention.
What you should not eat
in the way of bushmeat,
what you should not do in the way of
preparing bodies for burial,
people listened to them.
So having that trust is important.
And to have that trust
you need to listen very closely
to the communities that we are serving,
that you will be serving.
So I think that's probably
the single most important quality.
Maybe you could call it empathy.
Maybe you could call it good listening,
but you need to feel what the people
you are serving are feeling.
And to see life through their eyes.
And if you can, you can help them.
The other thing that I
can see in our world is
it is going to be
essential that we move on
primary health care and that
we move in digital health.
So understanding digital health
and what its capacities can be
in high tech, low tech,
no tech environments
will be very important.
I mean, right now we move vaccines
to little refrigerators out
in the rural communities
that have one little solar panel
that keeps them running day and night.
That is one kind of a low tech solution
that's affordable, that we can
put everywhere in the world.
And you need to know all
of those kinds of solutions
because digital health is coming.
Artificial intelligence is coming also
so that you can remotely diagnose,
and you can do it over a cell phone,
but we don't have it in every place.
And we are trying to connect
the other half of the
world to the internet.
We are trying to connect
every school in the world
to the internet in the next five years,
if we can do it.
And if we could
then it means every
community would be connected
and every primary health clinic.
So those would be good skills to learn,
in addition to that very
important but difficult one
that's empathy of just listening
and feeling that you
are with your community.
- Linda, sorry, you're on mute.
- Sorry, I knew that.
Maybe we'll do one more,
one more of the questions
from the Q and A,
Someone has asked about concerns
in working with adolescents
on sexual and reproductive health
about how can we reassure both
adolescents and their parents
that it's safe to return
to services and care?
And if there are any insights to be gained
from previous emergencies like Ebola?
And I think that also ties
into what we've talked about
increased domestic violence,
child marriage, you know
an access to just reproductive
health services in general.
- So in the news today was
one of those wonderful stories
about a hospital in which a
number of mothers had come
because they would accept mothers
who tested positive in COVID
and they were coming there
to deliver their babies
and this hospital accepted them.
So they were getting a good experience
on how to deliver healthy babies
that are not testing positive on COVID
from positively tested COVID mothers.
So an experience from
one hospital like that
is a very important experience.
And it's one that we need to pass along
to a number of other countries
and villages and towns and cities,
because everyone needs that prenatal care.
And you need the care
before, during and after
the birth of a child.
So obstetric care is way down.
I mean, I wish that
people were coming into
the primary health clinics
and into the community centers,
but they're staying home.
So that then means that
midwives who are out in the villages
are exceedingly important.
And it means that they need water and soap
so that they can try to keep everything
as hygienic as possible.
The second example is from HIV AIDS.
So there are many young people,
particularly adolescents
who want to test themselves for HIV AIDS.
They also want to test
themselves for COVID.
They want to be self-empowered.
And so they want a self test kit.
And we're not very good as a world
in developing self tests,
we tend to develop tests
that a doctor gives to us
or a nurse gives to us,
and then that's enough.
But young people want that.
And they want to tell each other
about how to keep themselves safe.
So one of the areas we've been encouraging
is the young people talking
to other young people.
There are young people who have decided
to open up HIV AIDS clinics,
and they're operating them.
They're all 17, 18, 19,
20, 21, 22 years old,
and they're operating the clinics.
It's not an adults clinic
it's for adolescents, for
adolescents by adolescents
and they really believe in it.
And young people tend
to flock to those places
because they trust their age mates
sometimes more than they trust us.
So I think there are lots of ways
to get health advice, health
prevention, health treatment,
out to adolescents and
at least some of the
lesser serviced areas
in ways that we just have
not thought of in the past,
but the world is changing.
And I think we can come out
of this stronger and smarter
about how we can reach more
of the millions of people in need.
- No, that's great.
And I think that's a
very useful perspective.
We have a question, an
interesting question
in the sense that, you know,
it's about UN Resolution 1325,
and for the audience, who's
not familiar with this.
This is a resolution that reaffirms
the role women have
in conflict resolution,
and there is proportionate impact
they suffer from conflicts
and, you know, similar stuff.
And it says that, you know,
UN agencies should include women
in security responses.
The question is,
pandemics are the global
health security you know,
catastrophe or issue that we are facing.
Any thoughts on, you know
UN Resolution 1325 and the pandemic?
- Well, it's right on the mark.
Women can be massively
helpful in peace negotiations.
So we are trying to think
through as the United Nations,
how to link humanitarian,
development and peace together.
As you all, well know,
the women are on the frontline
of being healthcare workers.
It is predominantly women.
And part of the difficulty for women is
that when the schools are closed
and they need to be home with children,
that their job is that
of working in a hospital
or working in a school.
And that's where they need to be.
And it's hard for them to also be at home.
So women are really being pulled
in many directions at this point in time.
But if we are all sensitive to this
and give a chance for
more, home health care
flexible work hours,
ways that women,
we can make it easier on women,
they are a powerful force.
In the most recent negotiations for Yemen,
there is a group of women
who have been activated
to be part of the peace negotiations.
We are also seeing that now
in some of the countries in the Sahil,
we've been seeing in a number
of places around the world
but this is a force
that is just beginning.
It's very promising.
We all have to get right behind
it and try to encourage it.
And we need to be thoughtful
about the lives of women that
we are giving them enough time
and space that they can look
after their responsibilities
at home as well as their responsibilities
in their profession.
- Very nice, Linda, do you wanna go next?
- Sure, this is more of a,
kind of a broader question
but I think it pulls together
a lot of the different things
that we've been talking about.
But what are the recent
COVID related setbacks
and really major barriers now
to achieving the sustainable
development goals
related to child health in particular?
- Well, gosh, it's hard to
know where to start on that.
I mean, we're very worried
that we've gone back 30 years.
I mean, as a world, we
have really done well
on a lot of the indicators for children
like child survival and
stunting and wasting.
But now we are very worried.
We just do not know if
we can hold the gains.
And in fact, it looks like
we cannot hold the gains.
So what can we do about that?
In my mind, it is that
we need to be innovative.
There are so many innovations
that our world dreams
of and puts into effect.
I mean, when you walk
through a refugee camp
you will see some very
creative ways to filter water.
And they're using often, a mask
or a little bit of their tent
and they're creating a fiber
filter for the water faucet.
That's just not far outside their door
but we need to look at frugal innovations
and very sophisticated
innovations and put them to work
so that we can take advantage
of the new world that exists
and reach more people more effectively
which is why I've
mentioned digital health.
It's coming, it just hasn't
come yet ubiquitously
to our developing world, but it's coming.
So aren't there some innovations
that you have seen somewhere
in some part of the world
that we could be putting to use
that mean that we can
leapfrog the technologies.
You know, I grew up in the
era when you had a
telephone that was wired
into the wall at home,
and it was attached
you didn't move, but then cell phones came
and I mean, you never look back.
We need all of those in the health sector
and in the education sector.
One of the things that this
generation is telling us
is that they care about
digital technology.
They want to use it,
they're empowered and they
are going to put it to use.
So therefore the more that we can create
an internet of good things
that we can teach them
and share knowledge,
we've just launched a
Global Development Commons
that some students have
been helping us with
from Yale and a number
of other institutions,
so that you can get answers
that you've been wanting to get
on a Global Development Commons.
And this will all be
in our internet world,
but it's an exciting time
for what we can change in the world.
And one will be distance learning.
I mean, there is no
reason why we cannot have
remote learning, distance
learning in every country
in the world.
Whether it's by radio, television,
SMS, tablets, internet,
we could do this as a world.
This is one of those once in
a generation opportunities.
And if we can do that for education
we can do that in health.
- So the next question is
one of our teen participants.
So we have a few non Yale attendees.
And this comes from a person
who has a very sort of interesting
and inspiring organization
that she has set up.
She's a high school student in California,
she has set up this
organization for other teens
to get teen adolescent
immunization rates up
in various communities.
And obviously we know that
that age group is an
area of focus for UNICEF.
Her question is
that, you know, what role
could the independence
of young people play in
increasing vaccination uptake?
And so, some of my work
has been sort of consent
in a sense of teens versus parents
when these choices diverge,
and for certain vaccines
there is that situation
when teens want it and parents don't.
And sometimes vice versa.
So any thoughts on that?
And, you know, I know that
autonomy is a major factor
in terms of working with communities
but what happens.
are there age specific
cutoffs where after which,
even if you are a teen
that you're more empowered
to make decisions, et cetera.
So any, any thoughts on that dynamic?
- So I think that the best way
to arm a campaign is something
that you said earlier, Saad.
You said, good evidence.
So marshal the facts
for what you know of about
the immunization campaigns
for let's say, small pox, measles, polio,
and then share those facts,
become a trusted resource.
Misinformation is very
difficult in our world,
but if we can help guide our
sister and brother adolescents,
to the trusted information sources
they will read and learn for themselves.
And it will make a difference.
But Saad, if I may say
it sounds like this young
lady would be very good
to give us advice
for what she thinks would work.
I've noticed that our SMS
world is very effected
if it is by someone that they know.
So whether it is an age mate
that they do not know,
or it's an age mate who
may be as a celebrity,
Millie Bobby Brown and I
have done a couple of events together,
but you know someone that you trust,
that you would listen to
that you think knows your
conditions and wants to pitch in.
I think that's gonna be very important.
And then Saad, if I could
just say about the future
I think that we have been
working in an old model
in which we thought that we adults
would come up lots of solutions
and that we would train and pass it on
to the younger generations,
but that's not true now,
the young people want to be part of it.
So they want to roll up their sleeves
and discover and find solutions
just right alongside us.
And I think we all have to now
reorient our programs to that.
Let them be equal partners
in finding the solutions.
So I'm ready to hear from
our activists on vaccinations
to see what we can do to help.
And let's start some campaigns
that will really work
if they work for the young,
maybe we can convince
some of the older kin
to also follow suit.
- Very nice, Linda.
You put yourself on mute, yeah.
- Yeah, got it, yeah.
So this I think is a perfect followup
for what you've just said,
Executive director Fore.
Many of the participants
who are attending today
just like many of the young
people you've talked about
either are already
looking for ways to engage
and will be moved to action
based on what we've talked about today.
And do you have any specific suggestions
or even general suggestions
about how people can
contribute locally and globally
to improving children's health
either through direct
engagement, targeted advocacy
or by supporting different organizations
that are working in the field?
- So, Linda we talked about this earlier
and you said something that is just right
which is begin, start,
take the first step.
So just start small start anywhere.
It doesn't matter where it
can be a local food bank.
It could be in a local hospital or clinic.
And it doesn't matter where you are.
You can tele-work to help,
or you can in-person help.
And then if you are so inclined
keep going in your studies,
be broad in your studies.
You never know what you're
going to need in life.
So try to learn as much as you can.
Don't specialize too early
because your world is
gonna be even more diverse
than the world that Linda
and Saad and I have lived in.
So learn everything you can.
And then just come out here
into the field and join us.
We need you, we would love to see you.
And it's a big world that
has a lot of needs right now.
So we need all of you,
every single one of you to
come out here and help us.
- Yeah, one thing, if I
may, I take the liberty
to ask you to put your former
USAID administrator hat on,
this is a changing,
this is a season of change.
And I look outside my window,
there are a ton of leaves out there,
and it's a moment of transition for the US
in more than one way
not just the weather, but otherwise.
So that's irrespective of what kind of
administrative of political
change is happening,
these moments are a good time to reflect
where US institutions should go.
Especially external facing
institutions like USAID.
Any thoughts on how does going forward,
USAID engage with the world?
Anything you would do different, you know,
not based on what's
happening now, et cetera,
but forward looking
what would be your thoughts on, you know,
USAID as the kids say a 5.0,
the new version of USAID?
- USAID is an extraordinary institution
with a storied past, and they
will have a storied future.
So the first would be to resource it.
USAID and its expertise lie in its people
and in their memories
and in their experiences.
So one needs to hire, train, mentor,
get them out there in the field
and they will be brilliant.
But for that, you need resourcing.
So number one is resource it.
Number two is we have some
extraordinary legacies.
I mean, what happened
with HIV AIDS and PEPFAR
is a story of health that
everyone is proud of.
Polio, we are so close.
I mean, we are really close.
We could get this done
in the next few years.
And if we could rid this world of polio,
it would be a great achievement.
So focus on a few things
that would change the world.
And that is always important.
Whether the institution is USAID
or whether it is UNICEF.
But USAID carries the flag of America
and thus American institutions,
corporations and foundations
have a chance to showcase
many of their innovations,
their digital creations
that will change our world.
COVID means that every country stops
and re looks at its
budget and it reallocates.
So let us make the case
that we reallocated for a better world,
a world that includes everyone
and that there are no children
or grown-ups that are left behind.
And if we can do that as a
world, it will be a better place.
And USAID will do its share and it's part,
but it is all hands on deck side, Saad.
And as whether you're a USAID
or UNICEF or anyone else,
we need everybody out there.
We also need to make the case
that what happens in the world
matters to people in America.
And sometimes one thinks
that one's own household
or one's own community
is the limits to what you can affect
but one person can make a big difference.
And if you keep in mind the
needs of the world around you
you'll see that there is a
world out there that needs help
and that you, as one person can do a lot
or you as a big important agency
like USAID can help change the world.
- So I'll take the liberty
of sort of before I thank you
to ask you one last question.
There will be
you know, a big catastrophic
or consequential events
in general have changed
the international system.
The second world war changed
the international system,
the great recession, or at
least the great depression
had an impact on the international system.
This is an event.
This pandemic is an event
that impacts everyone.
And you sort of function
within the UN ecosystem.
How does the international system change?
How does it change for the better?
Because you have had a
somewhat unique perspective
that you have led USAID.
Obviously you talked about USAID's role,
but also, you know UNICEF.
So both a country perspective
and a global perspective,
how does the the
international system change
for the better, hopefully?
- Well, there are a couple
of areas that I think
are big opportunities for us.
One is we do not yet
really work as one team
on the public sector side or
in the private sector side.
And it's due to a lot
of different reasons,
but COVID does remind you
that the great research
institutions are private.
The corporations that are
creating the vaccines are private
but many of the distribution systems
I mean, UNICEF, is part of this
in procuring and distributing
could be a mix of public and private.
And then when you get out
into the field into the most
rural and remote communities
it tends to be almost completely public.
But couldn't, we reimagine a world
in which there is a public
and private agreement
on how to collaborate
in a much better way.
I think COVID can teach us this.
I think this is the moment for that.
And if I can bring up education again,
this is our time to connect
every school in the world,
to the internet.
If we can do that, it will
give a level playing field
for every young person in the world.
So they can all start at the same place.
If not, we will break
into haves and have nots
in a really unequal way.
And so this would be a great
equalizer in the world.
And if we could look
for those big important
once in a generation
opportunities, that will be big.
And then lastly, Saad,
you knew that I'd have to say something
for the young people,
but the young people want to help.
They don't want to be the beneficiaries.
They want to be the actors,
they want to do it themselves.
So as we're doing our planning
couldn't we have some young people
on every commission in
every forum advising us?
We started something
called Generation Unlimited
there're young people on the board,
there're young people advising us.
We have young volunteers
we have 2 million right now,
we're heading to 20 million.
I mean, young people have
to be included in this.
We're all in this together.
And I think we will come out of COVID
and this time empowering young people
in a new and different way.
So public, private, and young
people and collaboration.
- So that's a good segue
into what I was gonna say
that you know, that's,
there are certain good things about Zoom
that you don't have to
sort of drive up I-95
to come from New York to New Haven,
but then there are drawbacks as well
that we can't have real two-way
interactions, et cetera.
So hopefully when things settle down
perhaps next year or in,
you know, 14, 18 months
you would find time to come back
where you could interact with our faculty
but more specifically our
students who are young and wise.
And well, wise well beyond their years.
And so, and I'm sure you'll
enjoy interacting with them.
And so hopefully you know,
that's after, you know,
as I said you know, I have
when this is over list
and hopefully we are on
your when this is over list.
Come back and have another interaction
with the broader Yale community.
So thank you for that.
I wanna thank Dr. Linda Arnold.
I wanna thank others
who helped us coordinate
and put together this event.
And I especially wanna
thank Director Fore,
for, so not just her insightful comments
but her passionate pleas
for engaging young people
and looking forward
and connecting the world
and focusing on building.
If I could, you know,
ascribe a subtext to it,
to building a more resilient world
that every time there is a catastrophe
disproportionately impacts the weakest
and the youngest amongst us.
So thanks for taking time to do this
and thank you everyone
for signing in to,
for logging in and being a
part of this event, thanks.